y es igual a un octavo de x cúbica - x
cuadrada sobre qué intervalo la función
divx tiene una razón de cambio promedio
de un medio así que vayamos intervalo a
intervalo calculando la razón de cambio
promedio así que primero pensemos en el
intervalo que está aquí donde x está
entre menos 2 y 2 - 2
es menor
x que es menor que 2
así que pensemos cuál es el valor de la
función cuando x es igual a menos 2
entonces evaluada en menos 2 es igual a
un octavo por menos 2
el cubo menos -2 al cuadrado lo que es
igual a vamos a ver menos 2 al cubo es 8
negativo menos 8 / 8
- 1 - 2 al cuadrado es 4 positivo pero
luego vas a tener que restar eso
entonces es menos 4 y esto es igual a
menos 5
y evaluada en dos de valuada en 2
es igual a un octavo por 2
el cubo menos 2 al cuadrado menos 2 al
cuadrado eso va a ser igual a un octavo
por 8 es 1
y menos 2 al cuadrado es menos 4 que es
igual a menos 3
entonces si quieres encontrar tu razón
de cambio promedio tienes que averiguar
cuánto está cambiando el valor de tu
función y dividirla entre cuánto ha
cambiado tu x así que podemos hacer una
tabla aquí podemos hacer una tabla
aquí
x cuando x es menos 2
entonces es menos cinco cuando x es dos
positivos que es menos 3
entonces cuánto cambio y james cremento
se incrementó en dos se incrementó en
dos y x se incrementó x se incrementó en
cuatro y puedes obtener estos valores
puedes simplemente verlos se incrementa
de este punto a este punto y x se
incrementa de este punto a este punto o
puedes decir menos 3 menos 5 negativo es
2 positivo esa es la diferencia entre
menos 3 y menos 5
si decimos todos menos dos negativos
esto te da una vez más la distancia o la
diferencia te va a dar cuatro pero si
ves esto está claro que mientras x
incrementa 4 que incrementa en 2
entonces nuestra razón de cambio
promedio sobre este intervalo va a ser
nuestra
envío
pero me dio
y con respecto a x
spector
x
va a ser igual
mientras que x cambia en 4
en 4 positivo que cambia en 2 positivo
lo que es igual
y medio así que parece ser que la razón
de cambio promedio sobre este intervalo
justo aquí sobre este intervalo justo
aquí es un medio por lo que tuvimos
suerte esta vez nuestra primera opción y
esto es de opción múltiple por lo que no
tenemos que seleccionar más de una aquí
la primera cumplió con nuestro criterio
por lo que sabemos que es la respuesta
pero déjame hacer otra de estas opciones
para mostrarte por qué no es la
respuesta entonces encontremos la razón
de cambio promedio entre este punto y
este punto entonces hay que hacerlo
hagámoslo en otro color lo haremos en
morado
así que 0 es menor que x
que es menor que 4 sólo haré una tabla
aquí
x entonces cuando x es cero cuanto es
que va a ser un octavo por 0 - 0 que va
a ser
cuando x es
4 cuánto es que va a ser vamos a ver un
octavo trataré de calcularlo mentalmente
un octavo un octavo por cuatro al cubo 4
al cubo es
64 un octavo por 64
8 va a ser ocho menos cuatro al cuadrado
que es 16 8
16 es menos ocho menos 8
entonces en esta cuando tenemos que x se
está incrementando en 4x se incrementa
en 4
qué pasa con ye ya ha disminuido en 8
por lo que la razón de cambio promedio
de ye con respecto a x aquí es que
cambia puedo escribir mi cambio en g
esta letra griega delta es el símbolo
para el cambio
el cambio en yes -8 mientras que me
cambié en x
es 4 por lo que la razón de cambio
promedio aquí es menos 2
es negativo porque mientras x incrementa
y disminuye y para cada en promedio para
cada incremento en x de disminuyen 2 por
eso obtuvimos s menos 2 aquí
así que claramente la razón de cambio
promedio de este no es un medio y eso
confirma que esta no es la respuesta y
sabemos también y los invito a que las
prueben también que éstas les van a dar
una razón de cambio promedio diferente a
un medio positivo